今日は
皆さんに
ご報告がございます今年の目標
もう行く決めようっていう話をしてたんですけども
決まりました今年の目標は
これからは
お菓子を食べませ
ファー付ウール
わー
の入れる理由があるんですよ
ううん僕はお菓子大好きなんですよだーった動画と無関係なく日常的にお菓子おくん
ですよ
黒子入る時も寝る前もゲームする時もどこでしすると4ページ打撲合唱食べてきたてる
ぞ
あああ
僕が気づいてしまったんですこの年になってこれ以上箇所食べると体に悪いんですよ
バーン
ネットでですね色々調べたわけですよおかしいためな交換とかチョコレートの食べ過ぎ
ておなかニキビ動画ができてるんですけど肌をきれいにしたいと思ったらちょっと食べ
ないとか根本的解決と買ったチョコを食べない生活を3年
してる方がいたねっていうのは無茶苦茶肌がきれいになったと言っててお肌がきれいに
なりたい
お肌の乾燥と治るみたいです取らなくなるんですよ
goo
ちょっと不利だが国が実家にいたときはお菓子を食べ過ぎてて夜ご飯が食べれなかっ
たってことがあってよく怒られてたんですよすごい頭が高い高いどれもとても高いで
そのお腹が付いた時に最初に食べるものの吸収率ってすごい高いね
もしお腹が請求的にお菓子とかを食べるとそのお母さんね油とか砂糖とかねというのが
一番吸収される
それとても
かなり良くないんですね僕はですね今年はちょっとガス代
食べないで美味しいご飯しっかりした食べ物をしっかり食べてしっかり栄養をとって
きっちりとしてまず食生活を見直すさだと思います
東莱だよ
ずいぶんで決めたんだった最近じいちゃんが糖尿病になったので僕も糖尿病になるかも
しれないですよ
本当にヤバイですよでもお菓子食べ過ぎるとずれてものはない
もうずーっと薬飲めませんブーンず様々な x 地の方が下手したら砂糖の量が多いか
もしれないので呪術
お菓子はこの動画をもちまして今年は食べなってやむを得ない場合は食べますけどやむ
を得ない場合を食べますよ星生菌さんがお土産でお菓子を持ってきてこれ食わねえと
殺すぞといわれると食べますよそれ
僕は自らお菓子を食べる生でもしませんし食べません今年はその場で美味しいご飯を
食べればいいんです
おいしくて健康的で体にご飯お腹ペコペコ6ときに食べるのが大事だと思うんですよ
メリットとしてはダイエットにつながるお花が綺麗になる直生活が良くなる多分
メリットは大きいですよ
家コソボで控えるどうぞよ
いいんですよいいんです頭にはなかった俺は水でも好きな時名前も食ってたん
our また低下としてたわけですよ俺は
バーン
ここにあるお菓子は全部食べますそこには僕の好きなお菓子を全部買ってきましたこれ
を食べれたら僕はこれをもちましてお菓子は食べなくなりますそこのご飯のボロボロの
人で部に切りたくさんの人こういうのは全部ねー
お菓子が原因なんすよそう思うぞーなんだよなぁ
お菓子が全ての根源で美味しい味ってタマ姉
調べた期末にもだめだでもなかったチョコ
だけどれその代価を払ってるんだぞなあということなんだよ
いますかないっすよカエルの g て帰るのはありますかないんだよ
中途半端な覚悟でやってるわけじゃないんですよ私だか曲で僕ちょっと今回決めてるん
でもしお菓子を食べるようなまでがこの先あったら
坊主にしまう絶対坊主にする平均さんがを消化し金とぞするとみたいな場面になると
食べますけど第三者が管理ない状態で僕はお菓子を断固として食べませんおいしい
ごはんを食べます今後の僕を見守っててください
マジで食べませんかいうわけで今日の増加では最後にお菓子を食べますいただきます
まいとつのその甘さ
岡瀬っていうのは人を幸せにするんだよ何度助けられたことか
辛い時もあったし話時もあったフェでお前ら食べるとなぁ
これ頑張れたんだよここまでがジェっていうのはいい
人を幸せにするんですよ心からででもそれでいいじゃどうしようもないときでぶレズよ
これが未だです
岩しかないんですよ僕は
お菓子等を乗り越えてもっとすげえ奴になるんだよ
ああ
うーんこれは運
沢山の箇所
食べて食べて食べまくったん
そう
こちらな所
忘れないように
一つ一つ
大切に
味わったなぁ
もしますねすけおかしい欲しいためにていいよ
me
ame